it's christmas as you can tell by my
appropriately seasonal lights
so i thought it was time to review an
appropriately seasonal game
which i realized is a joke you would
only get if you had played the game
evidel is one of those rare games that
promises you
so much and delivers on so many
of those promises but
you may not be interested in whatever
dell promises exactly
evidel is a worker placement resource
management game where you pick up
resin and twigs and berries these cute
little things and
pebbles and you build a city the biggest
bestest funnest city for your little
critters
hedgehogs squirrels rabbits and beetles
so that they will have a
beautifully warm and happy winter
when it comes over the course of spring
summer and autumn leading into winter
you place your workers and collect
resources and you'll spend those
resources to get your city cards
which can give you even more resources
or special abilities that make it easier
for you to get better cards in the
future for your city
but with only 15 spaces for cards in
your city you do
have to be very selective about which
ones and the best combination
of cards to have with your total victory
points from your cards determining who
wins at the end of the game but
crucially you don't just get points from
individual
cards but combinations of cards that
work better together kind of like
sets so in a game of evidence you're not
just trying to get the best
most expensive cards in the game like
the evertree or the castle or the king
or queen
for example the husband and the wife go
really well together and they only take
up a single space in your city which is
awesome and they're worth more points
than even the king or maybe you'll get
the theater which gives you an
additional point for every
other construction every other building
in your city
kind of like it and that's not to
mention that there are also quests up on
this tree here which
give you even more points if you have
certain combinations of cards that
are randomly generated from game to game
and one crucial game mechanic in
evidence that really changes how you
play
especially with these combinations in
mind is that every credit card
has a home somewhere that they live and
if you have that card in your city you
can take the critter that lives there
for free which is brilliant especially
in games where
berries are particularly difficult to
come by and the real strategy of evidel
is that it's never easy to tell
which path or combination of cards is
going to yield you the most points at
the end of the game
especially considering the cards that
you pick up or the cards that come out
on the meadow and you can
buy from both your hand or from the
meadow that everyone has access to
well they're unpredictable you don't
know what's going to be coming out of
here you don't know what you're going to
pick
up so if you're banking on a particular
card
to come up to make your strategy work
it's a pretty high risk thing to do
because some cards
even though they're great are pretty
rare so part of playing evidel is being
flexible it's about keeping multiple
paths open to yourself at the end game
while also making sure that the paths
you have
will bring you the most points and the
balance between those two things
is hard the end result is that evidel is
an incredibly skillful and immersive
game of managing not just
resources but picking up the right card
combinations and balancing
different types of cards you need to
maximize your points
and this is one of the real strengths of
evidence that i've found now
some several dozen games deep into it it
strikes the
perfect balance between deep and
simple decision making which a lot of
games really struggle with sometimes
it's
super complex but the decisions that you
make don't matter
that much or the decisions are so simple
but
they're honestly not that deep they
don't require much thinking evidel
doesn't have that problem in fact
where you place your little hedgehog or
your squirrel worker or which
one of your few cards that you can play
you pick to put down in your city
often has a pretty simple effect
in fact you might not even be choosing
between that many options
but which one you pick is usually
incredibly important often
massively impacting the direction that
you and your city can go a lot of games
suffer from
complexity overload where there are so
many decisions that you can make that
oftentimes you suck
not because you fail strategically but
because you just didn't see something
that you could have done
which is never fun it just makes you
feel dumb
and useless but evidel doesn't suffer
from that problem
you can pretty much always see all of
the different spaces that your hedgehog
worker can be placed or
which cards you can play so the strategy
isn't in actually making sure you're
aware of all of your options you pretty
much
always are it's in picking the right
option for you and on top of this i
mentioned that flexibility is a big part
of playing evidel
so the cards that you pick or where you
place your work is
do also restrict where you can go in the
future because you want other resources
you
won't have the right card combinations
to make it worth it but
i've also found that it never does this
to the point that it
forces you into only one course of
action you're stuck with
a single strategy you can usually from
season to season
change the strategy that you're going
for because with each season
passing you get all of your workers back
and more
i was playing a game with my girlfriend
last night and she absolutely
thrashed me with way better decisions in
the first and second seasons
but in the third i managed to really
bring that back and i ended up beating
her by just a few points and yes
i am using this whole video as a chance
to gloat
that i am now the evidel champion laura
i beat your high score
excuse me uh on with the review
like the thematic evidel tree there are
so many branching options in a game of
everdell that
even when you can't do a lot of other
things that another player can
you can almost always do a lot of the
things that they can't
there's enough freedom to be creative
most of the time
and enough restriction to keep every
decision you make
meaningful which is really important
if your decisions don't restrict you in
some way then
which decisions you make often don't
really matter part of this comes from
the game setup which varies every single
time due to the forest cards and the
quests
there are half a dozen basic locations
where you can get the same resources
every single game
the bread and butter pebble wood resin
and berry
but each game you will also draw out a
few of these forest cards randomly which
create new places to get resources
and they're way more powerful i really
like this mechanic because there a small
detail that dramatically impacts how you
play
if you can get a lot of berries then you
know that credit cards will be a lot
cheaper this game
so that combination where you work with
the building that they live in and then
take them for free that's less
important giving you more space to spend
on other cards
if you have a game where you can get
lots of pebbles then building cards will
be cheaper
and this affects which quests you can go
for and which card combinations will be
most easy to get and which ones will be
most profitable
because sometimes having resources left
over gives you even more points
i've played a good few dozen games i've
ever done now and i can tell you that
which quests you have up on the tree
always leave me thinking hmm which ones
can i go for
you know which ones can i actually
realistically achieve because i know
that if i go for this one i probably
won't be able to go for that one
it's great so what i'm trying to get at
here
is that evidel is a puzzle that changes
every single time that
manages to stay and feel fresh because
every single game
forces you to face different challenges
but
this whole engine building resource
management card management foresight
foreshadowing
whatever system might also reveal
why ivadel may not be for you
if adele is more a tactical or reactive
game than it is a grand
strategy game it's hard to have these
grand plans that pay off and
huge numbers of victory points because
you can't rely on certain cards to come
up and even if they do your opponent
might pick it up
or they might buy it from the meadow
before you're able to
for example you can get a huge number of
points by using the monastery
but it really requires you to get a lot
of spare wood or berries to make it
worth it and you really do need the monk
cart
which is pretty damn rare by itself it
may not even come up the entire game
if it doesn't then you're out of one
city space and you built your economy
for something
that never really paid off likewise the
quests only require you to get maybe two
different cards
but if you get one and bank on the other
coming up and it never does
then that's wasted space often wasted
cards wasted resources
and i cannot tell you how many times one
of the cards might come up in the first
round
and you buy it and then you wait for the
second one to come up
and it doesn't for the entire game and
you're left there thinking at the end
i would have beaten you if it just came
out
just the one card that i needed and
that's it
and that's really annoying i've
mentioned that flexibility is a big part
of evidence strategy and flexibility by
the way building a city that is able to
adapt and change that is a skill
that's a genuine game mechanic that a
lot of people will enjoy
but for the people that really like big
setups and big payoffs
it's not something that will really
entice them and the result is that doing
well in evidel
is partly a reactive thing it's about
buying the best card in the moment from
your hand or
from the meadow with knowledge of what i
can do
within the spring or summer or autumn
thinking in terms of just the next few
turns maybe rather than 10 or 20 turns
down the track because
you don't always have a huge amount of
control
about what the game will look like at
that point now none of this is to say
that these plans
can't pay off for example in my last
game i bought the monk and i managed to
get the monastery
and i also got a bunch of other cards
that allowed me to reactivate those
cards over and over and over
and i scored like a third of my points
from
just the monastery and the monk alone it
was incredibly
satisfying it does happen and you can
do it but it doesn't always do that if
you're a twilight imperium player then
maybe evidel isn't for you and hey this
is kind of why evidel
isn't my favorite game i don't dislike
it but
i love spirit island where everything
can be planned out and you can set up a
grand strategy and watch it
pay off and you can't really get
derailed by mere chance
chance is a good equalizer in games it
can make it easier for newer or less
experienced players to
catch up that can make calculating with
the decisions are going to pay off more
exciting when you're rolling a dice or
you're
not quite sure if something's gonna come
up when you need it and that's okay
that's great some people really really
love that and as i said the seasonal
structure spring summer autumn allows
for a soft reset of the game for players
to kind of go oh this strategy isn't
working i'm going to try something else
that's great it's really forgiving and
allows you to be flexible but chance
nevidel also plays a different role
it really does change how the game plays
out every single time
it makes every game fresh and variable
and new with a different puzzle and
different challenge
but that comes at the cost of grand
strategy a lot of the time
and that's a payoff that the designers
clearly chose to make and i must mention
that the meadow which is kind of like
the store that everyone is competing for
cards from
as opposed to your hand which is like
your own private stash
can get bogged down with cards that
nobody wants
because come the end of the game
everyone's really bought the cars that
they want from the meadow leaving just a
bunch of
farms and minor moles and wives
and i would be lying if i'd said i'd
never go to the other players and go hey
does anyone
does anyone want any of these cards and
the entire table will be like
no and so we just wipe them and get some
new ones out
but there is another element that i
really do want to mention theme and
accessibility this game
is beautiful every single card has
stunning artwork the board is gorgeous
the little
resource tokens are bright and vibrant
the tree
totally unnecessary but really draws
your eyes into the game and really makes
the whole thing pop
doesn't it it's a game that really
immerses you in what it's
trying to get you to do build a city
and you don't just think of it in terms
of what it gives you more berries and
resources or abilities
you kind of do think hey i'm getting the
husband's home he's going to live at the
farm or
i'm going to get i'm going to get the
wood carver who lives at the storehouse
and the fact that all the cards work
together so well like the combinations
of cards aren't random but
thematically coherent does make you kind
of think that you're getting a
particular
type of city working with a particular
type or
caliber of critter let alone the fact
that
the little workers are great and cute
and i love them
but it's also really accessible the game
is really easy to teach
it's really easy to get into newer
players will know
pretty much how the game works by the
end of this first season with the later
seasons being way more important
and that is great there are so many
familiar elements to this game that you
see in other pretty
family accessible games you know things
like
settlers of katan you've got resource
management
you're building different buildings
albeit in cards
and you've got little workers that you
place around the place
and that's really enticing for a lot of
people so if you are
someone who has say a family group that
doesn't
really play board games or you've got
friends who who like board games but
they're not going to be playing twilight
imperium or scythe
anytime soon evidel is a great
step up from whatever kind of more basic
games you're currently playing with them
it's a little bit more complicated but
still
plays to a lot of those themes and veins
that they will be familiar with
will probably be more fun for you as
well
so i can totally recommend everdell
especially to uh people who you know
love
games that involve resource management
and worker placement
don't be too derailed by my criticisms
of the grand strategy stuff
i am someone who loves grand strategy
games but
i still really like evidel that's me i
think that's all i got to say
let me know what you think of evidel
down in the comments
below stay nerdy and i'll see you in the
future